Fantastic.
Itai Sadan, thank you for joining me
on 20 Minute leaders.
Thank you for having me.
So great to have you.
I'm so excited to chat
because you're gonna tell me
one of the most fascinating stories,
I think, that one could tell
in the entrepreneurship space
which is identifying an emerging market
out of a garage in Mountain View
with one of your best friends.
But I'm not gonna give away
the whole story.
Itai, how did Duda come about?
So, it came about in late 2008
and me, and as you mentioned,
a very good friend that I know since
actually since high school,
we were both here in Palo Alto
working back then for SAP.
And we were, for a very long time,
we were trying to come up
we always knew
we wanted to do something together,
we just didn't know what it would be.
And we probably had
a thousand different ideas
that we thought about over the years
and shut them all down
for different reasons.
And then walking,
the actual idea for Duda
didn't come up in the garage.
It actually came out while walking
around on University Ave in Palo Alto.
I know you live in Palo Alto
so very, very close.
It's the one street that has a bar in it.
So, everybody knows.
So, walking to the Apple store.
Okay.
This is the same Apple store
that Steve Jobs also used to live
right in the neighborhood
and he used to visit that
same store as well.
And looking at that
first version of the iPhone,
the first version of the iPhone
came out in 2007.
Right.
And we were playing around in 2008,
and it just dawned on us
for the first time
that the entire Internet
was moving into this device.
But who knew?
I mean, iPhones came up.
They were great.
They were tiny.
The real first,
real good touch interface.
How did you realize that, wow,
yes, internet is moving to mobile?
'cause we were both engineers
and we played with all the technologies.
There were phones before that.
There were Blackberries
and there were Nokias,
and we were programming
with stuff like WAP
and it just was not the experience,
it was a very different experience
than going to your desktop
and getting the full experience
of the browser.
And suddenly that same experience
that you would get on a desktop
was for the first time available
on a small smartphone.
And we knew that they got it.
They they did something right.
And we were looking back then
at some of the first companies
that took advantage of that phone
and created their dedicated mobile site
like Amazon.
Did m dot amazon.com
and m dot eBay.com and so on.
And you just had a different
They also created
a very dedicated experience
for the mobile phone
for all these mobile users.
And we're looking around
and we understood.
To build something like Amazon
was able to do for a mobile phone,
you needed resources.
You needed specific skill set.
You needed budgets, know-how.
And it's a whole different
learning experience, right,
like the whole user experience.
I mean the whole adaptation
you have to make as an engineer.
I know as a web developer myself,
building for the phone is not the same
as building for the desktop.
Now, okay, Amazon can afford that, right?
And so, can eBay.
But what about the dentist,
or the owner of the pizzeria?
Or, take all 200 million
small businesses out there.
Clearly they don't have the budget,
the know-how, and the resources to do that.
Right.
That was kind of where the epiphany of,
we're gonna help the little guy
be able to create a store
very easily, very simply,
so that they can actually compete
against the bigger guys in the market.
Incredible.
So, the first product we launched
was called back then,
the company was called
based on the first product, Duda mobile.
We were just about converting
desktop sites to mobile site.
Wow.
And we started working on that
in very late 2008.
That's just incredible.
So, you were working on that
about a year and a half
after the first iPhone comes out
and really the world
gets introduced to mobile
and a fun user experience that is actually
comparable in the amount of things
you can do to the computer.
I'm gonna give a small spoiler.
10 years later, Duda has over
800,000 websites that it's hosting?
That is correct.
800,000? How do you even,
I mean looking back, in 2008,
you're sitting there in the garage
in Mountain View at this
beautiful, picturesque moment.
Do you even think that you're gonna get
to 800,000 websites built with Duda?
Well, it always sounds like
an overnight success,
but it's an overnight success of 10 years
with a lot of ups and downs in between.
And I remember in 2009,
we built the first prototype
and we were back to that same street
on University Ave kind of knocking
on small business doors and asking them,
"Do you want a mobile site?"
So really starting one by one
and getting these small,
at least to validate the product
and that there was a real need.
And it was also, remember
2008, 2009 was a pretty tough time.
Yeah. Who has money for this now, right?
Yeah. We went to investors.
Nobody wanted to invest back then.
Nobody saw the need.
It was really tough
until we had a really great break
in early 2010,
when we did a deal with AT&T,
back then AT&T Interactive, part of AT&T,
that saw the opportunity
and really wanted the technology
in order to sell to their
small business customers.
Wow. Incredible.
Duda. What's Duda?
So Duda is a, the product involved -
Not the product, Itai, the name.
The name Duda? What's Duda?
Ah, the name. Of course.
The Dude, The Big Lebowski.
Have you seen the movie?
I have not, but I read your bio
and I know the quote
and tell me the quote anyways.
Okay. Next time you have to do a prep
before you do a call with me
but yeah.
So, see the movie.
I'm sure you'll enjoy it.
I'm actually, I'll send it to you.
So there's a really,
many people know it.
It's a cult movie.
The main character is called "The Dude"
played by Jeff Bridges
and both Amir and I, my co-founder,
we're big fans of that movie.
I probably watched it tens of times.
Oh, my God.
10, 20 times.
My girlfriend screams at me
when I watch a movie more than once,
so she would have a heart attack
she's gonna have a heart attack
watching this.
Yeah. So, we started watching it
back in college in Israel
and it became part of the culture.
If you're coming to our offices,
you'll see different,
all the conference rooms have names
from the movie.
There's the Ringer,
Urban achiever, the Rug Room.
It's a really funny movie.
Yeah.
I think you wrote that your favorite quote
from the movie is about a rug
that ties the whole room together.
You have to see the movie. I can't
Yeah, but yeah
The whole story starts with
the main character's rug gets stolen
I love it.
Itai, you transition,
you're very very successful with Duda
and now you're also very big
in venture capital.
You're a part of the J-Ventures Fund,
which I'm very happy
to be a part of as well.
Part of Tel Aviv partners,
mentor at UpWest Labs.
You invested in TripActions, right?
Pretty early on.
Yeah. Yeah.
In the seed round.
Wow. Okay.
Ilan Twig, the CTO is a very close friend.
I invested in Ilan.
Back then, they said
"Travel company, something."
I said,  "I'm investing in you."
He's a good investment then.
Turned out to be
a very successful company.
I just had a really great chat with Dovi,
which we released pretty recently.
And one of the things
we were talking about
was impact investing
in his whole investment thesis.
And I'd love to know
because you're not
a full time investor, right?
You're a part time investor.
You're doing it.
You can see from your background
that you're doing it out of fun.
And you're just as much a mentor
as you are an investor.
So, talk to me a little bit
about this strategy of yours
and how you cover with companies.
Yeah, it's really,
I do it as a side hobby.
I wouldn't consider myself
a real investor.
It's just when there is
an interesting opportunity
and unfortunately I'm so busy
in my day to day work that -
I would hope, you're responsible
for 800,000 websites
so please be busy.
Yeah so, I would say most of my eggs
are in that basket, but once in a while,
if there's something,
someone I believe in,
some opportunity, usually tied to people.
It's really tied to people that I know.
Definitely.
Then, here and there.
I don't do it a lot,
but it is fun when I do.
I love it.
And it's fun to,
I mainly enjoyed working with them,
sharing my experience,
discussing challenges.
And yeah, so I think
that's really the fun part.
Itai, I wanna talk about emerging markets.
It's very rare to meet somebody
who identified an emerging market
was right, rode the wave,
went through the challenges,
raising capital,
in 2009, trying to get customers.
I mean, I didn't do it myself,
but I can see why
it would be very difficult.
I want to be in your position.
I want one day to be able to sit down
and think of a new market
and really ride that wave
and know that, yes,
I was right and I made a dent.
'cause you did.
You made a huge impact
on the Internet world
and SMBs presence online.
What are some of your insights
looking back on identifying
emerging markets and riding that wave?
Yeah. I think, the first,
it's important to find a real pain point
and where there's enough people
who share that pain point
and where you think you can come up
with a very unique offering
to solve that pain.
And I think we found that
in late 2008 and
with the first product.
Right.
I think you always need to come back
to this whole product market fit, right
This is basically what I,
building a product that fits
with a certain pain in the market.
Right.
The fact that you've found it
doesn't guarantee that
it will last forever,
and this is where I think over the years,
we had our ups and then we had our downs
and now we're couple of years of another,
like found it again.
I think this is the role
of the entrepreneur, of the founder,
really to make sure that
that product market fit is maintained.
But it's very hard
to get product market fit
on the get go when you're looking
at an emerging market, right?
Because they don't necessarily understand.
They don't have iPhones yet necessarily.
They don't understand that
this is where things are headed.
So, it's kind of a chicken and the egg.
Right.
Are you letting the market take over first
and then you're gonna go
and try your luck?
Or are you gonna try
and be on top of the wave?
And how do you get
your first customers on board?
Yeah. I think, it's the hardest
to educate a market about something
that they don't know they need.
But I think,
when we came out with the idea
for mobile websites back then,
we validated the idea.
We put some ads on the Internet
and because if there's a pain,
then people are looking for ways
to resolve it.
They might not know what the solution is,
but we bought some
... campaigns around
build mobile website,
create mobile website.
And the first customers,
we actually used our own
the technology was not ready
to hand it over.
We used our own technology to build sites
almost like an an agency, as a professional service.
So, just to validate that the technology
that we built was good enough,
it took probably a year like that
until we got to a place
where we could hand it over
to other people to build website
on behalf of small businesses,
or give it directly to small businesses
to do it themselves.
Right. What were some of the most
unique challenges that you faced
as the CEO?
You're starting out in a garage
with an idea.
You're running from door to door
to try and sell this,
and all of a sudden you're growing
and you're scaling and success comes
and investors come.
What do you tell yourself?
Who do you go to?
What are some of the things
that you experience?
Yeah. Yeah.
There's a lot packed in that question.
A lot.
Well, we have five minutes.
So, I'm sure we can get
through everything, right?
Okay, yeah. I think,
what I would say is that,
I think when you're growing
and you're onto something and scaling,
growth solves a lot of problems,
it creates problems,
but it also, when you see growth,
then investors see growth
and they want to invest
and I think that's easier to solve.
It's kind of rich man's problems.
There are problems that come with growth,
but those are solvable.
I think the harder challenges is is
when you're not seeing,
when it's not that clear
or when markets change.
And that happened to us.
If I go to 2014.
So we were just doing,
think of 2010 to 2013
something like that,
we were just selling mobile sites.
We got to a huge amount of customers
buying from us mobile sites.
We had partnerships
with GoDaddy and Google and OpenTable
and all that.
And suddenly, it wasn't as suddenly,
but we identified a risk
because the web was moving
to responsive web design
and we're only on the mobile side.
And we were looking at this
and we're saying,
"Wow, we're at a risky place"
because suddenly there's tablets,
and there's mobiles and desktop
and people have browsers
on their watches and in their cars.
Nobody wants to build a site
for every different device.
And kind of responsive web design
rose as the right way to do it.
You build it once, it runs everywhere.
So cutting it short,
we understood
we needed to build for that.
We needed to develop our product
in that direction.
We built another product.
Basically, the product that you see today,
which is our responsive website builder is our second product.
That's the pivoted product
from the risk that you identified.
So we had to pivot to another product.
And luckily that we did it
'cause the decline started happening
to our first product.
And if we hadn't recognized
what the shift in the market,
we basically lost product market fit.
So we had to rebuild
a new product to fit
what the market actually wanted
and I think those were the tough years
of rebuilding that product
and relaunching on another product.
2014 to 2016 were two pretty tough years.
We even went through
a little bit of layoffs back then.
Wow.
And then eventually with
catching the wave again
with the new product,
we're now five, six years later,
obviously
we made the right decision.
And the company has grown significantly
since then.
But that was like
almost a sudden death moment there where,
and you know that
there's quite a few companies
over the history that kind of missed that, right
They had the product market fit,
if we're talking about phones
BlackBerry, Nokia.
I was just about to
They were a rubber company
did you know that?
No, I didn't know that.
So, they pivoted once
well to phones and to electronics.
They didn't complete the pivot though.
It's hard. It's hard to do,
and maybe for our next conversation,
we can talk about what it takes to pivot
and the challenges with that.
It sounds like to me,
it takes a lot of bravery.
And it takes a lot of confidence
in yourself and the team
to be able to say,
"Listen, we might not be doing
the right thing right now.
We did two years ago,
but things are changing.
And we're, again, going to have
to understand our market
and to be better again."
Now, take that.
Think of like at Nokia or BlackBerry
where you have thousands of people
selling product A
and you need to tell these people,
"Well, this product
that you're selling
that's bringing billions of dollars,
forget about it.
That's history.
You need to be selling product B"
Understand
how difficult it is to transition.
And the problem is that you can't wait
for the product to stop selling.
You have to know ahead of time in advance.
So, while you're starting to decline
to already start working
on the other thing
And that's the hardest thing
because then they're coming
and saying to you,
"What are you talking about?"
We're still selling."
We're making billions of dollars
Which marketer would give you real estate
on like the home page
to put in a new product
when everybody's buying the old product.
But this is the role of the entrepreneur,
the founders, to really understand
the dynamics in the market,
have the vision,
and persuade everybody else to follow that.
Itai, what are you passionate about?
What am I passionate about?
I love working with people,
I love working with the team.
I love the challenges.
Every stage in the company,
this is why it always stays interesting
because the challenges to get
to the first million dollars of revenue
is different than the challenges
to get to the 10 million
which is completely different
than the challenges to get to 50 million.
So, I think it just keeps it
very very interesting
and you learn a lot.
It's the best, best education
that you can get is actually
to try to build a business and to scale a business
and I think that's something
that I really enjoy.
I love it.
Itai, right before we leave,
I wanna thank you again
for this great inspiration.
It's such a remarkable story.
I love emerging markets.
I love sitting down and trying to identify
what's happening
and where is the world moving.
Ever since I started
with J-Ventures as well.
That's I think the biggest gift
that a new young entrepreneur can get
is to really try and understand
what are the dynamics,
how do markets work,
how do entrepreneurs work.
And, Itai, before we leave,
I need three words that best describe you.
I always manage to keep calm.
To be cool.
Things get thrown at you
from the left and from the right,
- You look very calm and cool.
and I think you need to know
how to cope with it.
So I think people, if you ask
people will tell you that
it doesn't matter
One day it could be good news,
the next day it could be bad news.
You need to plow through it
and continue to move on and improve.
I love it. Itai, toda raba.
I'm definitely reaching back
for some advice
when I have my own startup.
So, look out for that email.
And thank you
for your time and inspiration.
Thank you for having me. It was fun.
Take care.
Bye.